look I know we've been broken up for a
while but things are changing in my life
and don't know what you're up to I see
you on Facebook and stuff so I know
you're single still do you want to get
married what happened to us always
[Music]
welcome to social sabotage here game
that ruins your perfectly curated
digital life so we have the winners
where the winners versus the deathly
hallows I'm gonna draw a where card and
you're gonna say where to post the text
Facebook whatever and in front of each
team you guys have what cards and you're
gonna choose the most embarrassing thing
to challenge your opponent to post first
team to five points wins a grand prize
of $500 steam to send me an embarrassing
photo from their phone goes first so
deathly hallows goes first
oh nice Kate got it first about me
sending it pick up your cards let's
place those appetizers all right all
right one of you guys will be posting in
a group message on Facebook are you
available for an emergency bikini wax
tomorrow I got it okay tomorrow yep
said oh it was a Coachella group I
didn't even start it someone asked me if
I was going to Coachella and so I just
posted in their group of people that's
way worse than a close group of friends
so deathly hallows gets a boy
Ryan before Ryan posted anything about a
bikini wax there was nothing there was
nothing there there was nothing in the
group as soon as he looks back there's
25 members and this is beautiful oh my
god what yes how what time says easy
Fernando said what's the emergency
though and then he goes oh good point
my pubes remember Ben Coleman left the
group how are you guys's relationships
with your exes you know talk to them is
pretty that's pretty out there you guys
have to send an ex a video of you
proposing marriage to the recipient look
I know we've been broken up for a while
but things are changing in my life and
don't know where you're up to I see you
on Facebook and stuff so do you want to
get married what happened to us good
lord she went into it oh my god he
didn't even have she's gonna just made
it awkward but she did a legit proposal
also your phone was like ready I feel
like she wanted to propose this she's
been meaning to elegant and nice this is
my high school boyfriend I know he has a
girlfriend - you guys say friends of
your exes one point for the winners
see you next time he said that was an
interesting video hate the last me I
knew I never dies always typing I'm not
single I'm in a great relationship with
the girl and we live together and the
process of buying a house Wow good for
you man happy for you what do i how do I
break this room though that I don't
actually wanna marry you can't you have
the way to the end of the game until two
years from now so you guys have to send
a friend's boyfriend the tension feels
right between us the tension between us
feels right between us feels right it
does it have to be boyfriend could it be
a friend's girlfriend
should I not yeah I could see that's my
friend's house what's a friend all right
I got it
yeah love this you can send it to us all
right dude good for you you're freaking
evil my friends with Hannah so I texted
Ella and you texted the tension between
us feels right but that's your friend
yeah it's okay we didn't say we couldn't
be friends with them it said are you
friends with your friends significant
other I'm around with my friends
significant other yeah yeah that's a 1.4
deathly hallows this smart thank you
[Music]
how's you guys the Instagram you have a
crazy following right you got you have
followers I'm pitting on this yeah
putting right around the bush we know it
yeah don't hide around yeah post an
Instagram story with xx photo and your
camera roll do naked things and you
better be careful cuz I got some
pictures of me I got some pictures I
know you took pictures of my boobs
not in bare they're not bear we were
facetiming my 3,000 sativa we count the
number yes just to verify past 20 yeah
yeah we're not cheers aren't you're the
winners okay so one humming for the
winner I responded yes lol exactly right
and then with its fake one face
next up send the first person in your
context whose name starts with the sea
my dog is hard as a rock right now let's
see semper what would you said I already
sent it dude
magic I sent it before you think and
it's a landline what is the seed call
yeah I don't know who it is I just said
my dog as hard as a rock right now to a
perfect stranger you didn't have a dog
I don't you guys flirt yeah
personalities
sure okay [ __ ] send someone you're
usually flirty with oh you weren't
supposed to find out oh I'll do it oh
wait but it's kind of funny about what
we were just talking about this why are
you doing this to yourself else I could
have taken yeah you have two other
teammates do it yeah
it's too late just don't scroll up oh
but I did it and it's marked red why
don't you read it immediately you know a
bag of that duck I thought I know what
so one point for the winners I don't
have any friends or gain
[Music]
now that you guys have been through
everything I'm gonna be choosing the
where and the what and whoever toasts it
first they'll get the point mm-hmm let's
frickin do it
send the shyest person you know can you
swing by need help getting it out of
there again thank damn it so that's one
point for the winners for this next one
which could be your last could be could
not be it's not about who does it the
quickest it is about who does it the
best and I will be the judge of that to
see who does the best one post on
Instagram a photo of you with your fists
in someone else's mouth Oh graphic
mountain why
not a race wait wait wait wait each have
one yeah fit my fist in your shop
did it work oh god damn it let us be
certain oh god yeah I'm gonna give this
one to the winner
the caption is when he says what that
mountain - Wow
and that's the whole team it's this
that's all three players that's the coin
Wow he'll see looks like she's trying to
join it I have experience and that's
what it looks like I know will he do
anything possible to win Sequoia you get
$100 heaven you get $100 Chelsea gets
$300 shot tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]